[Music]
so if people are listening to this audio
i'm at the skatepark now
tony hawk's
escape i'm at his place this is his ramp
and he's about to show me
him and his buddy andy are about to show
me the howie in person
and i don't mean me because i could just
stand in front of a mirror i mean the
actual
there goes tony hawk he's going to drop
into a howie
the fact that you are still trying to
create new tricks is there any
possibility that you would name one
howie soon
sure please yes i would love it
i would just love to hear my name at the
olympics like and now they should
they're going to try a triple howie
this is how we do it
this is i'm here with tony hawk and
we're at his this is
his place
you're not going to believe this area
right here
i think and this is real i'm not
bullshitting you there's a like uh can
you get a shot of not me
i think that's a leather love seat and a
three-seat couch and that is that
leather
wow
that's amazing tony tony take us down
show us the place yeah i'd love to share
my furniture okay
oh my god
look
it is they are leather
this is [ __ ] great tony [ __ ] hot
oh my god
this is amazing that's why i brought you
here do you want a tv or something and
even office furniture so we can watch
our stairs to that side as well
can you move out of the way
what come out here
i'm just setting all right oh man look
at that get out of the way
this is how i do it this is called the
blind side drop-in uh i would promote
you i would uh you know whatever you
need from us we're here for you and uh
just volunteer yourself to be on a guest
on art shows i would do it i would do it
all right probably not all the way are
you where do you film here san diego
what
did you come to my rap though
we'll do a full exhibition for you
[Applause]
you didn't drive in for this i did no no
you didn't no you didn't i absolutely
you're lying what else are you doing
while you're in town so now you have to
go to san diego to do his podcast will
you call something a howie
i told you yeah he said yeah i'll you
backside bodybuilder lip slide that's a
howie i'm calling it howie so yeah i
gotta talk to you about that no it works
no it's the howie
i've done i've done it once oh right
yeah and then we named it the howie yeah
and i started thinking about how i could
do a variation the variation on the
howie okay going front side front side
howie and then i realized as i
visualized it
that i've seen andy do that trick
andy you've done the howie front side
he's done the front side howie i'm tough
to get you don't get me right away front
side i'm tough to get back side back
side's a little easier yeah like this is
easier
right yeah right right yep you gotta
work your way into howie's backside
alley you body varial lip slide did that
happen by accident and it happened
because i was trying to do it into a
different type of grind and i could not
i couldn't aim for my truck it was just
too hard to coordinate we're getting the
weeds but i end up landing on my board
on the coping instead of my truck and i
just thought i should just go with that
take out
and sometimes you're like oh here's
what's funny andy
that's how i started trying that trick
you're trying to grind he's trying to
nose grinding
that's the weird part
can we just say how he's not easy how he
is
howie's heart
andrea just said i'm playing hard to get
let's see what she did there
me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
fair argument let's go but get a shot of
me down there and then we'll fill
something up
[Applause]
[Music]